hands up if you can't wait for Pretty
Little Liars the perfectionist to
premier to help with the weight discover
all the theories about this spin-off
show keep watching to the very end to
find out the most incredible theory
about the link between Alison and Mona
it will blow your mind what a person do
you think I am well March 20th 2019 is a
big day on our TV calendar as that's
when Pretty Little Liars the
perfectionists premieres on free form
ever since they announced the spinoff
from Pretty Little Liars we've been not
so patiently waiting for the big day so
we're super excited that the wait is
nearly over so what should we do in the
meantime
well we're speculating about what the
new show has in store for original cast
members and newbies there are so many
fascinating fan theories about what will
happen and we want to share the best
with you of course we'll be discussing
the series finale of PLL plus the books
that the new show is based on so if you
haven't watched all seven seasons of PLL
yet or read the perfectionist books be
prepared for spoilers now that we've got
the spoiler alert out of the way let's
dive in the good news is you don't have
to have watched Pretty Little Liars to
enjoy the perfectionist and that's
straight from Marlene King who wrote the
pilot and is an executive producer on
the new series however if you are a PLL
fan then you'll find a lot of Easter
eggs in the new show so what does the
ten episodes series have in store first
things first let's get a little
background on the new show the action
has moved from Rosewood to Beacon
Heights and filming actually took place
in Portland Oregon
we know that PLL fan favorites Alyson
played by Sasha Pieterse aw and Mona
played by Janel Parrish have ended up in
Beacon Heights Mona I brought pie and
life is anything but perfect in this
seemingly perfect town three college
friends are struggling with the stress
of being overachievers and it all gets
messy when the town's first murder is
committed these perfectionists each have
a secret ally and an alibi so who are
they the main newbie is Sophia Carson of
Disney's descendants Fame who plays Ava
then there's Sidney Park from The
Walking Dead as Caitlyn plus newcomer
Eli Brown is Dylan
other characters include bran Thomas
King as Jeremy Plus Kelly Rutherford
from Gossip Girl as Claire Hotchkiss of
course PLL fans are going to be most
excited about what's happening with
their girls Ali and Mona so let's focus
on them first
why did Alison move the first question
we have to ask is about Alison's motives
for leaving home in the series finale of
PLL she was raising twins with Emily so
why is she now in a different town in
the trailer that was released in May
2018 we see Ali arriving in Beacon
Heights her driver asks what brings her
to Oregon she explains she's joining the
Faculty of bhu when he asked if she's
got friends there she says she doesn't
know his soul
however we cut straight to Mona's
standing at Ali's door holding a knife
and a pie its classic Mona behavior and
we'll get on to Mona very soon but back
to Ali showrunner Marlene has dished out
a few things
she told ET will definitely find out in
the pilot why Ali's making this journey
Marlene revealed that it's a personal
journey for Ali there's something that
she has to accomplish for her own sense
of self fortunately we won't have to
wait long to discover what that is and
it gets revealed right away in the pilot
story we can also listen to what the
actress behind Ali has revealed - Sasha
told ET that she's happy to be leaving
the teenaged persona behind and
exploring this adult figure that's
because she thinks it's such an
interesting way of exploring Alison's
adult side and also how Ali's dealt with
this space that we haven't seen yet
could that space be challenges in her
relationship with Emily
or difficulties in her role as a mother
after all she's going to be messed up
after having Emily's fertilized eggs
implanted into her body without her
consent did Ali find out the shocking
revelation in the PLL finale that Alex
used when to fertilize Emily's eggs
speaking of Emily what happened with
Alison and Emily naturally Emison fans
are concerned that there's no Emily in
the promos what's happened to their
relationship showrunner Marlene explains
that the challenge and starting point of
the show was to find out which Oh G cast
burrs wanted to be part of it and then
worked the storyline around that as the
original for Pretty Little Liars were
ready to go do new things Marlene had to
figure out what to do about ally and
Emily and what she did was to honor
Emerson's relationship and what we know
is their truth so that sounds like all
is not lost for Emerson in fact when
Marlene was asked if actress Shane
Mitchell might appear as Emily on this
new show she said everything is possible
but what about their twin babies the
great news is that we will definitely
see the twins but they're not babies
anymore they're toddlers as the story is
happening in real time the gap between
PLL ending and the perfectionist
starting has been neared in the
characters lives so the twins are now
about three years old and Moana is a
couple of years older but is she a
couple of years wiser let's investigate
will Moana be trustworthy we see in a
trailer that Moana is still up for
surprises like how she surprises Alison
when she stops by for pie knife in hand
will she be trustworthy in this new show
that question is all part of the
intrigue and mystery as Marlene says
Mona is Mona you never really know
whether you can trust her or not and
that continues to be here truth in this
new story we last saw Mona playing with
her living dolls Alex and Mary Drake in
the PLL series finale so we're eager to
find out if she's still keeping them
captive in her Parisian dollhouse the
good news is we'll definitely find out
what's happened and in a very key Mona
way Sasha has also spoken about how her
character doesn't know where she stands
with Mona but guess what Mona and Ali
become allies in this new show and as
Sasha says it's a very interesting kind
of dynamic that's because Alison's not
sure if she can trust Mona because let's
get real can you ever trust Mona it's
time for Plan B you need to tell me who
you are even more intriguing is that
Sasha says the way Mona ends up being in
this new town is very mysterious it's
also hilarious and Sasha believes fans
will appreciate the mystery there
there's going to be a whole new aspect
to Mona's character - and that's a love
interest who will Mona's love interest
be Mona was certainly fierce in PLL
and never needed a partner to define her
however we will get to see her in a
relationship in the spin-off Marlene
dished that it's Mona's turn to have a
lot more time dedicated to her although
we didn't get any teasers about who her
love interest might be we can speculate
about the new characters in the
perfectionist there's certainly a lot of
kissing action going on between various
characters in the promos it's possible
that Mona could be linked to any of them
romantically given all the twists and
turns we witnessed in PLL and she could
even hook up with a former cast member
given that there's a good chance many of
them will make cameos we'll other og PLL
cast members make cameos it seems pretty
nailed on that there will be crossover
cameos from the PLL cast Marlene has
said in various interviews that it could
happen
she told UT that everything is possible
especially given that the og PLL's
are incredibly supportive of the new
show Marlene said that they're always
welcome and she would always want to
find a place for them because there's
such a seamless transition to the new
show it's possible for people to drop in
Marlene also told TV Line that we can
expect to eventually see more familiar
PLL faces in beacon heights however
we're going to have to wait a little
longer as it won't happen in the pilot
as for the og cast members themselves
they all seem to be up for it too Lucy
Hale told ET she's excited for the
spinoff and would be interested in
having arya make an appearance Shay
Mitchell has said that she thinks the
fans would really appreciate it if Emily
made an appearance and it's the fans
that they really care about
I mean Never Say Never I'm just so
excited for them as for Troian
Bellisario she might be joining the
perfectionist in a different role behind
the camera she's had conversations with
Marlene about directing a future episode
of the show as for her character Spencer
making the PLL crossover cameo Troian
was a bit more tight-lipped she did say
however that if Ally and Mona are
showing up in this world then who knows
who else will show up and Marlene
revealed that she's continued Spencer
and Toby story in her head
Bobi are happy and living in
Philadelphia Toby's helping to build
houses for the homeless while Spencer is
getting her law degree so perhaps the
legal training will
in handy given the murder investigation
in the perfectionist
what will the perfectionist secrets be
of course it's not just about oh gee PLL
cast members we've got a brand new crop
of characters to get intrigued about and
it sounds like Sofia Carson's character
Ava will be the one creating the most
interest after all Marlene revealed that
ava has her favorite secret they all
have a secret but Ava's is pretty
awesome and pretty cool the truth
studying fashion designer is fierce too
and Sofia herself told et that not
everything is as it seems with Ava fans
are super excited to find out what her
secret is could it be related to why her
parents fled the country or does it have
something to do with her relationship
with Nolan Hotchkiss speaking of Nolan
we need to prepare you for a big spoiler
alert so stop watching now if you don't
want to hear it it's likely that Nolan
will be the character whose body is
found on their aliens in the pilot after
all he's the one who's murdered in the
original books by Sara Shepard and
Marlene told TV Line that we meet four
new characters who are perfectionists
but one of them won't make it to the end
of the pilot and in a promo we see how
Nolan's mom Claire Hotchkiss is setting
up surveillance all over campus perhaps
to catch his killer there could also be
a new twist that isn't in the books as
we've seen on PLL dying isn't just dying
this character might come back to life
Nolan could be the new Allison well Poe
Alison and Mona's roles be the
perfectionist is giving us a whole new
mystery and a whole new murder so what
will Alison and Mona's role be in all of
this we have to wonder if they team up
to solve the mystery or if they have
something to do with it after all as we
hear in the trailer everybody's a
suspect
even though Ali's got a job at the
University and is a role model for the
younger characters we have to remember
her questionable past on PLL andis leads
to one of the most amazing fan theories
yet courtesy of in three rd in the
original books there are five girls
Ava Kaitlyn Mackenzie Julie and Parker
we have Ava Kaitlyn and Dylan possibly
taking the place of Mackenzie
that leaves Julian Parker Alison and
Mona might well be taking their places
and that would be so interesting because
of the major plot twists in the books
about these two characters here comes a
massive
spoiler alert if you're ready to keep
going then we're here to tell you what
we discovered at the end of book two
that Parker actually died before the
events of the story and her character
has been a figment of Julie's
imagination feeling guilty for Parker's
death Julie develops a multiple
personality disorder she carries out the
murders when acting as Parker if Ali and
Mona are these two characters then could
Ali be a figment of Mona's imagination
or can Mona be a figment of Ali's
imagination mind officially Bologna what
secrets do you think the perfectionists
are hiding how do you think Mona and
Alison's relationship will develop and
the spinoff be sure to let us know in
the comments thanks for watching make
sure you subscribe to the things for
more videos like this one we'll see you
next time
[Music]